we're looking for the only thing I can  actually eat here wasabi peas  where is Ravi calls it O'Neill's rabbit  food no April O'Neill I knew that I knew  you you're on the news  yeah Channel six do you watch sure yeah  Oh every night your weather is always  accurate I'm a reporter  yes they actually just offered me the  anchor position Wow kind of a big  decision though I don't know if I'm  gonna take it it's a good problem to  have I am actually in between jobs at  the moment trying to decide between a  failed corrections officer and a lunatic  vigilante you should definitely go with  way to type vigilante I think it suits  me  hey did I get you too